[Musica]
perché realtà virtuale realtà aumentata
sono le prime tecnologie a trasferire
emozioni per capirlo andiamo a capire
prima di tutto che cosa sono e mettiamo
i puntini sulle i la realtà virtuale è
una tecnologia indossabile cosiddetto
visore con all'interno due piccoli
monitor il momento in cui lo indossiamo
appunto siamo teletrasportati da
un'altra parte siamo all'interno di un
mondo digitale all'interno del quale
nelle versioni più complete e complesse
ci possiamo muovere possiamo muoverci
nello spazio e nello stesso tempo ci
muoviamo nello spazio digitale ci
muoviamo dentro questo mondo virtuale
la realtà aumentata invece è una
tecnologia che aggiunge ologrammi
aggiunge informazioni digitali nello
spazio che vediamo quindi
fondamentalmente io potrei mettere qua
un ologramma continua a vedere lo spazio
fisico ma vedo anche un ologramma
digitale non riesco a distinguere se non
guardando bene la differenza nelle sue
versioni più semplici utilizza uno
smartphone quindi inquadriamo con la
telecamera attraverso lo schermo vediamo
un pokémon nelle sue versioni più
complesse e più complete come quella che
vedete in foto
anche qui abbiamo un dispositivo
indossabile che aggiungerlo g alla
realtà e anche qui ci muoviamo nello
spazio interagiamo con il fisico con il
digitale allo stesso tempo quindi
abbiamo questo concetto di spazio che
resta e che rimane come un filone
denominato comun denominatore tra i due
tecnologie infatti sono anche definite
tecnologie spaziali perché tecnologia
spaziale tecnologie spaziali sono delle
tecnologie che mescolano la realtà
fisica e la realtà digitale
lo fanno in una maniera interessante
perché noi ci muoviamo nello spazio
fisico e nello stesso tempo interagiamo
con lo spazio digitale per chi di voi
appassionato d'informatica conoscerà il
concetto di interfaccia l'interfaccia è
quella cosa che ci permette di
interagire con un personal computer
inizia con una tastiera poi si evolve
con il ma
lo schermo eccetera ecco queste sono le
interfacce definitive le interfacce che
tendono a scomparire
non abbiamo più bisogno di imparare a
utilizzare un mouse e una tastiera
perché siamo noi con il nostro corpo che
ci muoviamo dentro un ambiente digitale
e ci muoviamo in maniera totalmente
naturale così naturale che
fondamentalmente abbiamo un effetto
interessante per il nostro cervello il
senso di presenza che cos'è il senso di
presenza il senso di presenza è
fondamentalmente un grandissimo inganno
è un grandissimo inganno che il nostro
cervello subisce da queste tecnologie
perché se pure una parte quella
razionale del nostro cervello sa
benissimo che siamo in un mondo virtuale
che stiamo indossando un visore c'è
tutta una parte più cosiddetta prima
male irrazionale più antica del nostro
cervello che non è stata totalmente
cablata per interpretare il l'ologramma
dalla realtà fisica e quindi non ci
capisce niente
il senso di presenza è proprio questa
immersione totale che il nostro cervello
prova nel momento in cui siamo
all'interno di una di queste tecnologie
e quindi è appunto un inganno ma per
capire quanto questo inganno possa
essere efficace
andiamo un attimo a barcellona nel 2018
all'università di barcellona facoltà di
psicologia alcuni ricercatori hanno
fatto un test di imbonimento body swap
che cos'è lembo di mentre modi mente è
una tecnica si utilizza in realtà
virtuale
mi metto il casco sono in un ambiente
virtuale mi guardo ad uno specchio
ovviamente virtuale e vedo me stesso ma
invece di vedere me stesso o l'avatar di
me stesso vedo l'avatar di qualcun altro
cosa hanno fatto questi ricercatori
hanno fatto un test di intelligenza ad
un campione
dopodiché hanno preso un po di persone
l'hanno messa in un ambiente virtuale
facendogli indossare l'avatar di una
persona qualunque in un altro un altro
parte del gruppo le hanno messo dentro
un altro ambiente virtuale facendogli
indossare l'avatar niente popò di meno
che di albert einstein a valle
dell'esperimento dopo che sono stati un
po ognuno
nel loro ambiente virtuale hanno fatto
un test di intelligenza incredibilmente
quelli che avevano indossato la l'avatar
di einstein erano risultati più
intelligenti ma che sembravano più
intelligenti erano più intelligenti
quindi capite che sono tecnologie che
hanno un effetto placebo fortissimo sul
nostro cervello ma non solo c'è sono una
tecnologia che ci modificano lo spazio
in cui viviamo ma modificano anche noi
stessi quindi adesso se vogliamo non
attiri provare a trarre la prima
conclusione è ok
che cos'è la realtà la realtà è quello
che vediamo e su questo è fuori di
dubbio
i filosofi il sindacato né ce lo
dicevano il mito della caverna perché di
voi se lo ricordano la realtà fisica non
la conosci mai tu la conosci attraverso
i tuoi sensi
poi arriva ris toto nella metafisica
dice di tutti i sensi la vista è quello
che ti permette di conoscere meglio la
realtà è bene forse passati un po di
anni da quella volta ma adesso abbiamo
capito come veramente in realtà la
realtà è quella che vediamo è quella che
vediamo ex quindi possiamo cambiare
quello che vediamo in una maniera così
credibile da ingannare il nostro
cervello possiamo cambiare la realtà
quindi abbiamo visto che cos'è la realtà
abbiamo visto che la possiamo modificare
in maniera artificiale adesso andiamo a
vedere che cosa sono le emozioni ma più
che vedere che cosa sono le emozioni che
non sono la persona più adatta per
analizzarle in maniera scientifica che
andiamo a capire come nascono le
emozioni vi faccio vedere una foto
ora questa foto io mi immagino che non
dirlo non è che dirà tanto a nessuno di
voi forse vedete un po di quadri storti
dietro una famiglia felice che sorride
quindi emozioni zero se la guardo io
vedo la casa dove sono cresciuto che
adesso è stata venduta vedo la mia
famiglia 20 anni fa e quindi
evidentemente le emozioni che provo io
guardando questa foto sono ben diverse o
per lo meno io provo delle emozioni e
voi no quindi che cos'è l'emozione
l'emozione è il significato che il
nostro cervello da alla realtà e quindi
se vogliamo trarre una conclusione se la
realtà è quello che vediamo e l'emozione
è il significato che diamo alla realtà e
se quello che vediamo lo possiamo
efficare allora possiamo anche
modificare le nostre emozioni
questo è quello che intendo quando dico
che sono le prime tecnologie che possono
veramente trasferire in maniera
artificiale le emozioni che vogliamo e
non lo dico solo io
un'equipe di ricercatori dell'università
cattolica di milano sempre facoltà di
psicologia con la quale collaboriamo e
fin dagli anni 90 hanno coniato il
termine di tecnologie trasformati vera
realtà virtuale e adesso è conosciuta e
diciamo su tutti i giornali ma è una
tecnologia che nasce nel 68 e nei centri
di ricerca viene utilizzata da un bel po
e che cos'è la tecnologia trasformativa
la tecnologia trasformativa è una
tecnologia che ci permette di vivere
esperienze trasformative che cosa sono
le esperienze trasformative le
esperienze trasformative sono delle
esperienze che viviamo attraverso delle
emozioni che possono farci vivere dei
cambiamenti permanenti quindi sono
tecnologie che non solo modificano
quello che vediamo non solo ci fanno
sembrare più intelligenti ma ci possono
cambiare in maniera permanente
lo fanno in due modi anche qua
sfruttando l'emozione il senso di o il
senso di meraviglia per restare in tema
il senso di meraviglia che cos'è è una
una condizione mentale che proviamo
quando siamo esposti a situazioni che
trascendono i nostri schemi mentali
abituali quindi a meraviglia è quando
per la prima volta vedo un tramonto
incredibile una spiaggia caraibica e che
mi rimane impresso per sempre ma la
meraviglia può anche essere qualcosa di
spiacevole a un incidente dove rischio
la vita sopravvivo e la realtà mi cambia
da quel momento io vivo la realtà in
modo totalmente diverso
me lo ricordo per sempre
el altra emozione che utilizzano queste
tecnologie il senso di flop il senso di
flow che quella condizione anche qua
mentale globalmente positiva che io
provo quando faccio un azione sono
mentalmente talmente coinvolto che la
faccio molto meglio rispetto
alla normalità se pensate ad un artista
maurizio è un mio amico artista che ha
portato in questa foto lui riesce a
lavorare solo sotto effetto di flo
altrimenti non produce è però tutti noi
abbiamo provato sul lavoro piuttosto che
nei propri o bilal esperienze di flop
quindi di coinvolgimento emotivo forte
che ci permettono di fare il lavoro
meglio di lavorare meglio
quindi queste tecnologie riescono a
indurre in maniera artificiale il senso
di meraviglia e il senso di flow che
sono i due sensi che ci permettono di
vivere delle esperienze trasformative
permanenti possiamo cambiare come esseri
umani quindi una tecnologia che non solo
trasmette emozioni ma una tecnologia che
in grado di cambiarci come esseri umani
che roba incredibile cosa serve poi se
pensiamo a questa cosa come cosa bella
si e fascinosa ma se pensiamo a come può
essere applicata avremo delle sorprese
perché il primo campo di applicazione
anche qua fin dagli anni 90 e quello
clinico la cura del dolore cura del
dolore e la cura di tante altre malattie
e schepp rizzo che è un anche più
ricercatore di los angeles fin dagli
anni 90 utilizza la realtà virtuale per
curare il post post traumatic stress
disorder
insomma questo la malattia mentale di
cui soffrono gran parte dei soldati che
tornano il fronte no ma non solo questo
tipo di malattia può essere curata con
la realtà virtuale anche per esempio
danni cerebrali piuttosto che danni da
infarto piuttosto che l'autismo
tantissime malattie oggi vengono curate
utilizzando la realtà virtuale
oltre alla cura del dolore c'è la
collaborazione abbiamo detto il senso di
flo quando noi lavoriamo con il flow
lavoriamo meglio bene sono e
collaboriamo a distanza o in presenza
utilizzando queste tecnologie si attiva
il senso di flop e lavoriamo meglio
questa foto è una foto scattata a
durante un'operazione al cuore di una
bambina particolarmente difficile egli
chirurghi hanno deciso con una startup
italiana per la quale lavoriamo che sia
martines di utilizzare la realtà
aumentata perché era l'unico modo per
capire esattamente dove questo tumore
era posizionato nel cuore hanno dovuto
rifare un ologramma e insieme in realtà
aumentata
hanno collaborato in maniera totalmente
diciamo così coinvolgente per
individuare il tumore preparare
l'intervento e l'intervento è riuscito
benissimo abbiamo poi l'esempio
dell'apprendimento che forse uno dei
casi di più di maggiore utilizzo
soprattutto della realtà virtuale in
questo caso l'apprendimento è stato
anche qua studiato da poco perché questi
studi sono tutti abbastanza recenti dove
la realtà virtuale si è applicato all
apprendimento scolastico permette di
avere una retention formativa quindi la
gente gli alunni si ricordano di più le
cose è un efficacia formativa quindi
migliore ma anche un coinvolgimento
emotivo migliore perché spesso la realtà
virtuale è associata a tecniche di
gamification di gioco che sono quindi
più coinvolgente soprattutto nell'ambito
dell'apprendimento oppure anche
l'apprendimento in ambito aziendale
noi utilizziamo la realtà virtuale con
tante realtà aziendali per fare
formazione quello che abbiamo visto con
i test comparativi e che la realtà
virtuale permette di formare tre volte
più velocemente quindi si risparmia
tempo e anche tre volte in maniera più
efficace perché le cose si ricordano
meglio un altro caso d'uso interessante
è ovviamente il mondo del marketing
non è un caso se la prima azienda ad
investire svariati miliardi di dollari
nella realtà virtuale è proprio un
azienda il cui core business è fare
l'ottimizzazione di messaggi
pubblicitari
questo perché ovviamente se ci pensiamo
i nostri impulsi da questo sono molto
più guidati dalle emozioni che della
razionalità
se quindi io riesco a convogliare le
emozioni giusta
la giusta riesco a fargli spendere più
soldi e quindi a chiedere più soldi gli
advertiser oggi la realtà virtuale è 18
volte più efficace rispetto a un
annuncio pubblicitario tradizionale 18 è
un numero estremamente alto quindi qui
si apre la domanda un futuro distopico
non lo so però sicuramente bisognerà
fare attenzione
l'ultimo ambito e ovviamente forse anche
il primo in termini di fatturato
dell'industria li realtà virtuale
realmente realtà aumentata il mondo
dell'intrattenimento già oggi è la
principale fonte di guadagno videogiochi
ma non soltanto videogiochi
pensiamo alle esperienze e guardatevi
c'è il monte everest e quanti di noi
possono permettersi di spendere 100 mila
euro per andare a fare una spedizione in
cima all'everest
ma soprattutto perché io devo spendere
100 mila euro per andare in cima
all'everest
quando posso provare più o meno le
stesse emozioni di essere lì ma stando
seduto sul divano di casa spendendo
magari 20 euro per un'applicazione sono
domande che ovviamente fanno riflettere
e fanno riflettere tanto che ci sono
studiosi per chi di voi conosce harari
all'aria ha detto che il futuro
dell'intrattenimento soprattutto su una
grande fascia di popolazione umana sarà
la realtà virtuale perché ci sarà una
grandissima pancia di popolazione che
sarà resa in occupabile dall
intelligenza artificiale dovrà stare a
casa avrà tanto tempo da perdere pochi
soldi da spendere quindi l'unico modo
per provare delle emozioni e per
intrattenersi sarà utilizzare la realtà
virtuale che ad oggi è il mezzo
tecnologico più efficace per vivere
questo tipo di esperienza ora io non so
se questo scenario un po distopico è uno
scenario realistico no fatto sta che
quello che fino a 20 anni fa era nei
film di fantascienza oggi è nei negozi e
costa relativamente poco
io credo che oggi per la prima volta
nella storia
possiamo con un click
comprare o vivere tutte le emozioni che
vogliamo e penso che in questo modo
possiamo costruire la stanza delle
meraviglie più bella di tutte
[Applauso]